the jurogan experience i mean this
recent thing where
uh those folks went to the capitol when
they were standing
up on his behalf and then he throws them
under the bus yeah he threw him all into
the bus after it was over
yeah it's crazy i watched a video of it
i had not seen
much video of it yeah i'd only seen like
a couple of videos on instagram i was
like what the [ __ ] i didn't want to
get depressed and watch it but today i
said let's get depressed
and i watched a bunch of it i had no
idea how bad it was yeah in terms of
like the the sheer number of people like
storming the gates and screaming and
these small handful of cops that were
supposed to protect it yeah and that one
cop that got beaten
there's like a video of them hitting the
cop with flags and [ __ ]
yep it's like what the [ __ ] like what
how did that happen how did it
deteriorate to that i know man it's um
it's really sad to me that that that
kind of thing
happened and then you have these [ __ ]
cowards
rudy giuliani uh ted cruz uh
josh howley all these cowards
they are allowed to stand on their
pulpit
and and say these things like they're
tough
but they're nowhere around to support
these folks in the first place and
they're
sending them into the battle and now
they will
comfortably comfortably join the ranks
of their
members of congress while these other
people are going to go to jail and have
these
these charges which they should have of
course but
um these leaders who manipulated them
there's no consequences to them i mean i
think that's the real crime
yeah but we'll see if there's
consequences because i have a feeling
there will be for trump
i think this is going to be the end i
really do because i think there's uh
there's very little chance that he's
going to run in 2024 after this
because a lot of people were hoping for
that a lot of his supporters were hoping
for that
but after this i don't i don't even
think yeah i think the useful idiot is
done
i mean i think like the people like
mitch mcconnell and those people they
don't have no more use for him so he's
done
i mean he's already he's done enough for
them they're they're happy with what
he's
done he's delivered with the supreme
court and so forth
his time is over it's interesting to see
you know we've always known that there's
a certain faction in this country that's
fairly simple like not that
sophisticated not very smart and they
like thinking in like a real narrow
box and this guy came along and was
their guy
you know and then we realized like oh
like the [ __ ]
of this country were unrepresented and
all of a sudden they got represented
like there was a lot of people like a
lot of those folks that stormed the
castle that stormed
capitol hill like if you see like when
they get arrested and you find out who
they are like
a guy living with his mom believing q
anon conspiracies thinks the fbi sending
out pedophile codes that kind of [ __ ]
like
those guys didn't have a king before
what do you realize how many of them
there are but what about the guy
who was i don't know a lieutenant a
retired lieutenant
lieutenant colonel from the army or the
air force
i mean so there are people there who
also had
education and they were plugged into
society right there were a number of
those people too
right i'm sure there was a few yeah yeah
i mean i i think that
um um i
you know i i think most of us are simple
people
and that that's okay i think you should
be able to be simple
and have a decent life and um uh
and enjoy yourself i think that there's
no crime there i think that's
fine the real problem is that
we allow our leaders to lie
and then you can manipulate even the
most sophisticated among us
can be manipulated and i think that's
the real crime
so it's like not that these people were
simple it's okay to be simple
um maybe simple is the wrong word maybe
[ __ ] was the right word
there's a lot of people that are
[ __ ] honestly and there was never a
guy
who who said it's okay to be an [ __ ]
but i'm an [ __ ] too
do you think do you think that the
majority of these people were [ __ ]
i think they could be [ __ ] if they
were led the right way but can't most of
us be [ __ ]
i think at the worst moments of your
life yeah
yeah i think so but but you know i think
that
when you have i'm telling you man
i'm putting this square on those people
in washington
trump is one of them of course but i'm
i'm talking about the ted cruz's and
all of those people as well i mean those
people
they should be they should face
the criminal justice system for what
they did um
because these folks who are out here we
all have the potential to be [ __ ]
and then if you think that what you're
doing
is holding up the liberty that we we
promise in this country that you are
being a real patriot and you really
believe that you've been manipulated to
do that
by these leaders they should pay the
price
and that's the thing that's really i'm
really disturbed by
it's like yeah we'll we we should get
trump yep absolutely but we should go
after those other people
i don't know what did ted cruz do that
oh with the uh election
uh were you saying that the election
fraud election fraud when he knew that
he knew what time it was those guys
um they know they were being dishonest
i think it's a political ploy right
there's politicians
take stances based on where they think
their constituents
lean and you know stop the steal and all
that was trending and all these social
media sites
yeah and i feel like for a prominent
politician that's a
a manipulative person that looks at
these things and goes well that's an
angle that i can use
you're absolutely right joe that's
exactly what politicians
do and we should expect more of them and
until we do they're going to continue to
do that [ __ ] when they know
that is [ __ ] and so you're right
that's what politicians do
so you think so what do what do you
think they were trying to do anything
just
posturing to try to get those people on
their side
for the future that's right i think that
ted cruz and those folks were setting
themselves up
for a future presidential run or what
have you and hoping that they get
trump the king maker to endorse them
even though
trump called his wife ugly i would have
beat trump's ass
i mean i'm telling you i mean it's like
what kind of man allows that that he
called him lying ted
yeah i mean what kind of man allows
another guy to call his wife ugly and
not do anything didn't he also infer
that he was a serial killer or something
his dad his dad zodiac killer that yeah
his dad helped kill kennedy or something
he said
yeah uh but what kind of man does that
i mean i know allows that i mean i don't
understand that
well what kind of man wants to be a
senator you know it's it's a weird
business
and you get deeply entrenched in that
business and there's compromises that
you make and
a lot of weirdness i i understand but
you know like what kind of person want
to be president that's fine
i mean i don't want to do that but i'm
glad there are people that
that do it and the thing is i think we
should require them to be
more honorable than we do we certainly
should and
and so like when when people are
posturing
politically when they know that there is
no that this is just uh there's no
opportu there's no
chance that this election can be
overturned because
there's no fraud i think they should pay
a price
i think that is just too manipulative
but and i think their position
requires that they be more honest
and until we do until we require them
require them this of them then i think
that they
will continue i think there's a a
style of behavior
that lends itself to success like
business success and financial success
and it's like a speed style like people
that are into
amphetamines and people that are into
like getting ahead and pushing it
and i think that there's a a style of
behavior that leads itself to be
compassionate
thinking more about community and i
think that is more like
a marijuana style or a mushroom style
you think so yeah i do catch new
episodes of the joe rogan experience for
free
only on spotify watch back catalog
jre videos on spotify including clips
easily seamlessly switch between video
and audio experience on spotify you can
listen to the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode of the joe rogan experience